So my name is Nic Crane.
I'm a software engineer
at Voltron Data,
and I'm also one of the
maintainers on the Apache Arrow
project, and I work
mainly on the R package.
So I started learning R
about 12 years ago.
And I just got so excited
about the idea of open source.
I went from being like this
passive consumer of software
to now kind of having this thing
that I could kind of pull apart
and it was like
seeing the matrix,
seeing inside kind of all these
functions and things like that.
But despite that being
quite a while ago,
it took me about six
more years, I'd say,
to really start to connect
with the R communities
and another few
years on top of that
to make my first contribution.
So what I want to talk
to you about today
is kind of the things
that got in my way
and stop me getting
involved with contributing
to open source a bit sooner when
I probably actually could have.
And actually, like, it's
been so beneficial to me,
I almost wish I had sooner.
But first, so in the way
that everybody does science,
I wanted to do a Twitter poll.
So question for my
rstats folks who have
contributed to open source.
How many years have you been
using open source libraries
for before you made
your first contribution?
And actually, it was pretty
easy interesting to see that.
It was pretty nice to
see that for most people,
pretty soon, actually,
two to three years
of using open source libraries
before they kind of really
got involved.
But actually, it's
quite a lot of people
in a similar situation
to where I was where
six or more years before they
really of made that first leap.
So I'm going to start
off just by talking
about why contribute to open
source and the benefits it's
had for me.
But before I go
into that, I just
want to start with
a bit of disclaimer.
Like, I'm not saying that
contributing to open source
is necessary to be a
good software engineer
or a good data scientist.
It's absolutely not.
I think there's a certain amount
of privilege being involved
with even having the time to do
so alongside everything else.
So that's not what
I'm going for here.
But going back to
what I've gotten out
of contributing
to open source, I
feel like it's been
the best learning
experience of my
career and definitely
kind of contributing kind
of code and non code things
and getting feedback
from people has
been the biggest acceleration
of my development
as a software engineer.
Working in public is great.
You know, I figure
out something that's
taken me ages and I blog about
it and then somebody is like,
OK, I get it now,
really rewarding.
And again, it's great to
be part of a community.
And I think as well,
it's great to have
that proof of your skills.
Like, I'm not the most
necessarily confident person
as a software engineer, but
having those sort of bragging
rights, you know, like I've
kind of made those contributions
to that project.
OK, well, I guess I
must know what I'm
doing some of the time, then.
And I'd also just
like giving back
to projects that have
helped me in my work before.
OK, so that's kind
of the benefit,
but what are the kind of
things that kind of maybe
got in my way or some
quite common complaints?
So like I think one of the
flip sides of open source
being this kind
of massive network
of self-governing
communities is that it
has been quite kind
of OK in some bits
to have kind of quite strong
personalities and people kind
of not behaving amazingly,
in some bits anyway.
So I think I definitely
had that question.
You know, are people going
to be friendly or mean?
There's also the question
of not knowing how.
So I was at a point where I
could write functions and even
write R packages, but
I'd not made a pull
request or a project yet.
Other questions are things
like, what if I don't
have the skills to do this?
What if I don't
know where to start?
And even just that fear that
working in public is scary.
I get to share my
successes, but I'm also
kind of sharing
my failures a bit.
So just to get kind of one
barrier out of the way,
if it is literally
just the process of how
do I make a pull
request to a project
that is stopping you from
contributing to open source,
I'd say please do check
out the first contributions
repo that's kind of
looked after by forwards.
So I was involved in kind of
making the R version of this.
And basically, it takes
you through the process
of making a pull request.
So if you already a bit of Git
and know how to use GitHub,
that is all you
need to kind of just
walk through the kind of
mechanical steps for it.
But actually I think the things
that really hold people back
from getting involved aren't kind
of the actual process things,
and it's more these kind
of concerns or worries.
So the main bulk of
this talk is going
to be basically about
things that I now know
that I wish I'd known before.
So the first big question
I had is, how to pick,
where to get involved
and what to work on.
And I think this is just really
complicated by maybe the view
that I had of open source.
And I really had this kind
of slightly misguided view
at first
that open source is
one big community,
and that's just not true.
There are lots of open source
sub-communities and even
within languages -- within
R we see this right.
But I think even
kind of stepping back
from that kind of my
next view of open source
wasn't quite right either.
So to kind of illustrate it.
So this is a screenshot
from the movie Mean Girls.
Now, if you've not seen
that, like I'm sure
everybody at some point has
seen some TV show or movie
where you've got this kind
of American high school
cafeteria and the new
kid's walking through.
And it's like, are these
people going
to let me sit at the
table or are they not?
And that feeling of,
you know, these people
are kind of mean and these
people are kind of nice,
and things like that.
And this metaphor
completely breaks down
because everybody is nerds here.
But the point was viewing
it as these people
are mean and awful.
And these people are lovely
over here isn't quite right.
And I think with a lot of
projects it's easy to forget.
Like a lot of projects are
kind of staffed by volunteers
and there's a lot of reasons
why kind of some projects
just don't want
new contributors.
So they might be going
through a design phase,
they might just be really
small and it does take effort
to onboard a new contributor.
So I kind of came to
realize that is OK.
But then of course, like the
next obvious question is, so
if some projects don't
want new contributors,
then how do I find
the ones that do?
And actually, that
was way easier
to answer than I thought.
So, they'll tell you.
So, for example, this is an
issue from the Arrow project.
This is one that we've
labeled good first issue
to say, you know, this
is a good place to get
started getting involved.
And again, similarly, here's
I think this is an old one,
but this is from dplyr,
and it's been labeled
both good first issue and
help wanted, like clear
signaling like we want
people to get involved here.
I will say like projects
that don't have these labels,
it doesn't mean they don't
want new contributors.
But if this is a
concern of yours,
this isn't kind of an
easy way to figure it out.
So the next question
I guess then I had
is what to contribute.
And I think commonly
given advice
that I think is good advice is
all about starting small, build
up trust.
Show people you've
read the guidelines.
And you can kind of
go from small things
and bigger from there.
I think one thing that was
really important for me,
though, actually,
is it is way easier
to contribute to packages
that you use yourself.
So my first contribution
was to the broom package
and that went well
and everything.
But there were points during
that kind of code contribution
where I was like, I don't
know if I can change this
because I wasn't a regular
user of the package,
and it would have been much
easier if it was something
that I had a bit more kind
of day to day use with.
And of course, like if you found
problems in packages or bugs
that you've
experienced yourself,
that's a really great
place to get involved,
kind of figuring
out what's going on,
fixing it, submitting
a pull request. Equally
with documentation
you find unclear.
I feel like if you're
newer to something,
you're actually
an advantage here.
Like you're coming to
this problem with kind
of like a fresh
mindset and therefore
like if the documentation
doesn't make sense to you,
it's probably not going to
make sense to somebody else.
And that's a really nice
early contribution to make.
And just in general, if you've
got a specific maybe area
that you've got expertise,
domain knowledge,
that's also a great place
to go and kind of like
use that if it's a package
that deals with that.
OK so I think for
me, the really,
really, really big question
about how to get involved
was how to navigate
social dynamics.
And this is a really
tricky one because, as I
said before, every
project is different
and made up of quite
different people,
even kind of within
the same project.
Now there's this quote that
I really like, actually.
So this is a book called
Working in Public by Nadia Eghbal.
And if you're interested
in open source governance
and how these things work, I
would definitely recommend it.
Really good book.
But in the book, Nadia says
open source is complicated
because it contains a messy mix
of both technical and social
norms, most of which
play out in public.
And I think this
really gets to it
for me, like it's
figuring out how
to kind of change
something, make a function,
and that's one thing.
But just figuring out how to be
this new person in this group
and go out and not
annoy people and kind
of just get things done
that can be really tricky.
So one of the ways of
overcoming this, I think,
is a lot of projects
have participation,
have kind of contributing
guidelines and documentation.
So I this is kind of like
a screenshot of a page
that I really, really like,
actually. It's the Apache
Software Foundation
kind of member
participation guidelines.
And it goes into detail
even the minute detail
of how to kind of
phrase requests
kind of make significant changes
to make it kind of as, I guess,
as smoothly as possible.
I say this doesn't just apply
to Apache Software Foundation
projects, and it's
definitely worth kind
of skimming through these
if that's kind of a concern
that you have yourself.
But then the other
thing here I think
is like sometimes just
embracing imposter syndrome,
like you are new to this
thing and that's great.
But like if you are pretending
to be somebody that was there
already, what would you do?
So the answer could
be can go and read
previous pull requests
and previous issues
and look at the kind of
things that people do.
So like every
different package is
going to have something
slightly different
and it's always good just to
see what the conventions are
and to follow them.
I will say the one
thing to kind of add
to that is, as a new contributor,
it's sometimes better
to err on the side
of over communicating
rather than under communicating
because an established kind
of contributor might
kind of need to say less
to get something accepted.
But still, I found reading
those previous PRs
and issues has been
super, super useful.
OK now, this is a
really weird one for me.
Something I've noticed.
And again, this
is very different
between different projects,
but definitely on some.
There's this real
difference in social norms
and quite stark
differences between what
would come across a certain way
in real life versus kind of how
things look on a pull request.
So to step back a second,
we've got these projects that
have maybe got busy maintainers,
lots of different issues,
and there's a certain level of
bluntness that can appear rude,
but is people just trying
to get through issues
and just trying to get
as much done as possible.
And I've definitely had
to kind of come to terms
with having this real
duality of maybe seeing
that kind of feedback
and getting it myself
and not taking it as rude or
personal or anything like that
and just seeing
it for what it is.
But at the same
time, actually not
necessarily engaging in that
communication style too much
myself because I don't like it.
And just because
it's a normal thing,
it doesn't mean I have to do it.
But again, I can still exist
in that world and that is fine.
So my third question
then was what
does the process of getting a
pull request accepted actually
look like?
And this is another
one where I've really
had to kind of change
my, I guess, the way
that I view these
kind of things.
So previously I kind of
viewed it a bit like an essay.
So you kind of you're in
school, you do an essay,
you do your work, you check
it, you hand it in to somebody,
and then you wait a
bit and you get it back
and you've got some
kind of mark that's
an indication of your
skill or competence.
That is really not a good
way to look at a pull request.
Like, you will have a
bad time if you do that.
And the reason for that
is like a pull request
is more like a
conversation than an essay.
Like, the back and forth and
suggestions for changing things
and taking a different approach,
that is part of why one of
the best things about getting
involved in open source, that
is when you are really learning,
that is when you're getting
feedback from people that
are probably quite experienced
at this to improve things.
So, yeah, definitely not
treating like an essay.
And I think another thing kind
of around this kind of pull
request kind of
approach as well is
I found that coming
from a background
where I've been working
in kind of consultancy
and a bit of
software engineering
on proprietary projects,
working on open source libraries
is a completely different thing
in some really subtle ways.
And this is something that I
summarize as a task oriented
versus code oriented approach.
So when I was a consultant,
I would be working,
building things with libraries.
So the focus there is
getting tasks done.
You know, you might
be building an app
for a user that needs to
do a certain thing as part
of their day job.
You might have a known set
of users, or at least some
of them,
you could maybe go
sit down with them
and see how they'd
normally do that task.
And it makes it a
bit easier really
to kind of see what
they're likely to do
and what they're
not likely to do.
And you can kind of get
away with only testing
kind of like certain paths.
In these circumstances,
like dependencies
can be a lot less important.
Like you can add new packages
and it not be a big deal
and you might be
the only maintainer
or part of a small team.
So you can kind of do things
however you want as
long as it works.
But this is like
completely different now,
like working on open
source libraries,
like your users in your
tasks are mostly unknown,
which means you have
to be really rigorous
with your testing and even
kind of preventing paths
that you think no
one will ever take,
or testing things that you think
no one will ever use actually
does become quite important.
There's often kind
of a need to really avoid
adding extra dependencies
here, but that
can lead to really good things.
So I think sometimes
it can be easy to say,
right, I can't get this
working with this package.
Let's just use this other
one or a bit from both.
But when you're working on
kind of open source libraries,
you kind of can't do that.
But that forces you then to
learn to work with the tools
that you've got in
front of you and learn
that kind of last 10% of a
library to get a task done.
And I think, again, that's
been something that's
been really valuable for me.
And also just this
idea that you're
writing code that isn't
kind of your code.
This is to be maintained
by kind of maybe
yourself but other
people and the community.
And that means you
can't have these maybe
weird idiosyncrasies
or kind of code smells.
You've got to be
a bit more strict
about these kind of things.
And I think just
kind of realizing
that it's a really
different kind of mindset
between these two things
kind of makes it easier
to accept what kind of might
seem like pedantry sometimes,
but it's actually like
for a real good purpose.
But actually, like this isn't
even the right question.
Like, you could submit a
pull request to a project
and it might not get accepted.
And that could be a good thing.
It could, I don't know.
You could try to implement
something that doesn't quite
work, but it exposes
something else
in the package that actually
needs changing and updating.
And that's a helpful
contribution, right?
You figured something out that
can make this software better.
And actually, I
think the question
should be like, how do I make
a meaningful contribution?
Because actually when
I think about it,
I feel really good
about the code
that I've kind of contributed
towards kind of Apache Arrow
and stuff like that.
But actually I feel like some
of my most meaningful open source
contributions have
nothing to do with code.
Like I love writing blog post
when I've learned something
that I found difficult, and
then somebody else is like,
yeah, no, that
makes sense to me
now, finally. Like, I love
improving documentation
and taking that kind
of beginner's mindset.
I even like tweeting about
a bit of functionality
that is like not well advertised
and somebody suddenly like,
I can now achieve
something with that.
I feel like that's
kind of meaningful.
So to summarize, then,
open source is about people.
There isn't a single
open source community.
There's a lot of different sub
communities within the things,
and there's no one size
fits all approach to saying,
you should do this
here or you should
behave like that in that way.
It's about just figuring it
out for the thing that you're
actually looking at the time.
I think especially maybe as
a new, more nervous person,
like just find communities
that you want to be part of
and want you to be part of them.
Also just remember
everybody is new at some point.
And I think that
once you have done
the work of reading
the guidelines
and kind of a few previous
pull requests and approaches,
like after that, there's
a point at which you just
have to jump right in and
go for it, and kind of then
welcome that kind of
code review conversation.
But as much as I'm
talking about code now,
like open source
contributions are
about way more than just
code, and that is definitely
something to keep in mind.
Thank you.